préparez
ce détective Alex Murphy un officier en
bas nous sommes à la veille d'une
révolution technologique nous devons donner aux
Américains la figure qu'ils peuvent se rallier derrière
moi donne toi maman oui mon bébé trop lent
garçon nous allons mettre un homme à l'intérieur d'une
machine
[Musique]
il a subi des brûlures au quatrième degré sur 80%
de son corps s'il survit il sera
paralysé de la taille aux pieds confiné
dans un fauteuil roulant vous dites que vous pouvez le sauver
qu'est-ce que cela signifie quel genre de vie a
vraiment du sérieux c'est plus intelligent c'est
toi  l'enfer m'as-tu fait faire un
look plus pratique, allons-y
avec le noir
quand la machine se bat, le système de congé
libère des signaux dans la pluie d'Alex
lui faisant croire qu'il a le contrôle mais il ne l'est pas
c'est l'illusion du libre arbitre
j'ai sélectionné 13 cibles toutes recherchées  pour le
meurtre, c'est l'avenir de la
justice américaine,
vous devez parler à votre fils d'une
manière ou d'une autre, il passe outre les priorités du système,
un élément humain sera
toujours présent, la compassion, l'instinct de peur,
ils interféreront toujours.  e avec le système
ils sont vivants tu viens avec moi